hey what's up guys mary here with lee
ross that's associate project director
of zombies is with us give us all those
sweet tips and tricks for zombies mode
and call of duty and i'm here with rob
hanlery how's it going what's going uh
we're about to play some serious zombies
uh and i heard that you know all the
secrets i might know one or two uh tell
me about them secret
well we'll show we'll show off a couple
of things today uh but i want to leave
some stuff to discovery for our
community so i'm not going to give all
the keys to the castle away but we'll
definitely take a look at space land and
we'll see some cool stuff yeah you guys
have a rad community you have like
people who are basically like constantly
on like a subreddit like letting people
know when they found something and the
zombies is always been known for just
being riddled with secrets but before we
actually play around and get into the
secrets um let's
go ahead and look there was some other
stuff we wanted to see
um that you wanted to show us yeah from
behind the scenes
yeah so uh you know obviously you know
zombies is fun to play just by itself
but we've built in all these cool
systems that really make playing zombies
uh easier for the player we want we want
the players to succeed so we built all
these cool little things um so just by
by logging in every day we're going to
give players a login bonus where you'll
get these keys that you can use to open
crates and these crates for zombies
what's really awesome about them
is that
not only do you get stuff that you can
use in mp but you're also getting fate
and fortune cards which you can use in
zombies and the fortune cards that you
can get are really really powerful drops
so as an example let's open up a crate
um this is not one of the rare crates we
might not get something super duper cool
but as an example i'm getting a player
card and now i'm going to find out what
three cards i'm gonna have access to and
these are actually pretty cool cards
these are actually i got some fortune
cards which is pretty great
so
have people been utilizing their cards
like the way they should be like i mean
have you found that everybody's been
like using them or kind of keeping them
yeah i i think that there might be a
little bit of a concern that uh you
won't get your cards back that you'll
you'll spend your fortune cards and you
won't have access to those cards again
uh we're gonna flood the cards out you
know the more that you play uh the more
keys you're gonna earn uh if you log in
every day you're gonna earn keys so
there's gonna be a lot of opportunity to
get out there and uh and get access to
more of those really really powerful
fortune cards um in addition you can
always purchase cod points and cod
points can also give you the ability to
buy these uh these rare boxes and the
rare boxes whenever you get cards you
actually wind up getting two cards and
the the chance of getting a really good
drop is actually very very high
but if you wanted to just play you could
also get all these keys just by playing
absolutely so one other thing that i
wanted to talk about that players might
be overlooking is the prototype lab and
the really cool thing about the
prototype lab is you can actually add
some free additions to the weapons that
you buy off the wall in zombies mode so
as an example one of my favorite weapons
to use is the nv4 um and one of the
things that unlocked just by going
through the progression for me was the
ability to increase my ammo now we know
ammo is like gold and zombies right you
always need ammo so something like this
being attached to your weapon is
actually a really nice benefit um i also
one of my other favorite weapons is the
banshee um the banshee shotgun what's
awesome about is it's it's the first
really powerful weapon that you can get
access to when you open up the first
door in zombies in space land and what's
cool about this is that
because it's right near the entrance
you're guaranteed to get this gun all
the time now i've i can add stability to
this gun and all types of other
additions to it um just by coming into
the prototype lab and adding these
additions now you'll notice that i'm
sitting with that little 200 uh marker
on top of there
you can actually
gain that salvage back
every time you open up one of these
crates in zombies mode uh a daily login
bonus we give you those those salvage
points and again you can use them so i
have 245 i don't want to spend mine
right now um so i'm actually i'm saving
up for something really really nice
of that money but let's go ahead and
let's go ahead and jump in um and what i
would like to do
uh is i'd like to you can go into custom
game what i'd like to do is
um just jump into the barracks for a
second so i can actually show you guys a
little bit about what i was talking
about here
um
so let's go my loadout here now in my
fate and fortune card drop i'm going to
have my basic fate and fortune cards
these are the ones i'm going to lock
just unlock just through my progression
there's some really good ones in here
like blood blood clot um which increases
the time that it takes for you to bleed
out when you're in last stand but if i
go to my fortune cards by hitting r1 you
can see the cards capability gets
significantly greater so
one of my favorite cards is get packed
this card gives you the ability to
pack a punch one of your weapons
immediately so the minute you fill your
fate and fortune card you can have a
pack-a-punched weapon that's an absolute
game changer in zombies and this doesn't
require you to go through the
pack-a-punch easter egg so you can have
one of these weapons by seeing two or
three which is a really big benefit um
on top of that any of the additions that
you've added to your weapons
in the weapon kits menus
those all follow you in so we talked a
little bit about that banshee and i want
to show you why that banshee's so cool
if you look at my banshee uh it actually
has some cool decorations on it and if
you look at what i have going on here i
actually have attachments for this
weapon and i'm able to carry not only
a new site but i'm actually able to
carry five attachments
immediately when i pick up this weapon
now for me with the banshee i'm using
the smart shot the smart shot is an
incredible weapon because it actually
auto targets for you and so
having this weapon right away out the
gate i feel like i have a pack-a-punched
weapon before i've ever even even gotten
into the game so i highly recommend that
people come into
uh the weapon kit menu and explore some
of the things that they're unlocking as
they're progressing because it can
really change your weaponry and right
out of the gate it gives you a great
advantage for success in zombies okay so
let's go ahead and jump in and
i'll get that banshee and hopefully get
my mv4 and show you what those things
can do
once they've been uh equipped with their
their max loadout yeah and what we're
interested in seeing is not just like
your knowledge on just like the
different loadouts and um your knowledge
on like the cards and fortunes but also
all the secrets that are littered within
this world um all the stuff that the
community does
which is just i mean that's just
basically
what everybody plays this for is to find
those secrets absolutely for us you know
zombies in space land this was a love
letter to the 1980s you know it's it's
even little things like the the style of
the posters that we created yeah the
color and and kind of scheme of the park
and let's not forget the music i mean
can you guys talk about the music
choices for a little bit i mean that's
something that you guys have done such a
good job with yeah so really the the
main focus for music was us to find
stuff that was really diverse um the 80s
was very rich with a lot of different
types of music you know you had sort of
the the birth of rap music hip-hop was
really kind of taking its hold uh
classic classic rock was was sort of uh
turning into metal and a speed metal
so we wanted to get a nice diverse mix
of music that we thought you know uh
players could identify with and and
maybe even
you know go to itunes and start
downloading some of that music because
some of those songs are really classic
man
i find myself singing along to to far
too many of them while i'm playing the
game
so if you ever end up in the lobby with
me and i'm singing please don't please
so i wanted to point out a couple of
things that we did here these are just
kind of little tiny easter eggs but
um all the pictures that we have located
on the employee of the month here these
are actually all employees from infinity
war that actually helped make this game
there's just easter eggs everywhere yeah
so we have little things like this that
are peppered in that you'll see
ah i'm actually here but not not there
i'm somewhere else in the map and we'll
get to that
you never made it to employee of the
month i never made it to employee of the
month
i think i caused too much trouble in the
office
resident troublemaker
so i've got just about enough to get
that first door open so i'm going to go
ahead and flip on the power so we can
get out of this space i feel like you're
gonna be opening a lot of doors for us i
have no problem with that
be the guiding light for us so now that
we have the power restored in this area
we have access to up and atoms which is
awesome because if you go down
uh up in atoms is the thing that can uh
get us over to you and keep you alive
keep you in the game now here's my
banshee this is that gun that i talked
about as soon as i come out of that
first area this banshee when i pick this
up you're gonna see that i'm gonna have
quite a really powerful weapon
so i'm going to start off one of our
easter eggs
i'm going to pick up neil's head
and this actually kicks off the
challenge mode for the game anyone's
seen the rest of it and we're going to
kick off tier 1 challenges so these are
kind of these are sort of the easier
challenges that we're going to face
um but depending on what way we end up
with challenges they can tend to be
pretty hard
so neil is actually we're trying paying
homage to neil degrassi tyson with that
character so that's another little
easter egg
we love neil he's an awesome guy now
these challenges on the robot i believe
this brings uh kill zombies from a
distance now they they light up when you
do this isn't this to unlock the hop
yeah this is to get to hoff so now what
we're going to need to do here is we're
going to have to complete the first
round of challenges that neil is going
to give us within the time limit correct
he's going to give us about five of them
but what's going to wind up happening is
uh once we do complete all of them
neil's going to shut down and say you
know what i'm going to need something
else from the player in order to get me
going
so i'm going to break the the rules and
not
shoot from a distance because i'm out of
ammo
oh you don't want to do it
no you guys should do it but i'm not
going to participate cause i'm out of
ammo so i'm just gonna cause some damage
they're white when you do it i'll cause
some damage to them and then you guys
can fend them
off
yeah just so i can pick up a couple of
bucks here and there
and i'll get on the money train
yeah i highly recommend for players
starting off i know the first two
weapons are really enticing uh because
they're right there
i highly recommend to save your cash and
look for the weapons that are in the
first area and if not the first area um
one of the areas immediately outside of
that area
almost got my cash
okay we failed the first challenge
already
it's all right they just they just get
another one but it takes a little longer
now i just picked up a souvenir coin and
there's actually an easter egg tied to
uh well one of the easter egg parts are
tied to the coins so those coins that
you get they're gonna drop in uh three
different types you're gonna get red
blue or green depending on what you put
in the souvenir station you could get
the boom box you could end up getting
the fireworks trap but there's also
something else that you can get out that
triggers an easter egg as well okay cool
so we're gonna get we're gonna work on
getting that item as well
yeah we wanted the melees to be unique
for each person and i think that helps
really all right kill tens of deliver
their their character and make their
characters seem a lot more interesting
now their melees aren't necessarily more
powerful uh
but you'll notice that their ranges are
different um my fit my favorite
character to melee with actually is the
the nerd
his melee slap is just absolutely
ridiculous
and so i saw
a video this morning with the um kind of
like shade glasses and like that
revealing a bunch of targets around the
map and here the glasses are it's funny
that you mentioned that so i'm going to
go ahead and pick them up
and i'm going to work on
throwing some zombies while jumping so
if you notice my smart shot my smart
shot just auto tracks every single one
of these zombies
and so i have to do very little to aim
at them especially in challenges where
you're jumping around you have to move
fast that smart shot is really really
super helpful
so we're going to work on getting the
first area open
so we'll we'll definitely try and keep
getting the challenges done
but let's go into the journey to space
area this i highly recommend recommend
players taking the journey to space
route first
it gives you access to an assault rifle
in that space uh an smg in that space
and you're also going to gain access to
two doors that open you up further into
the map
we have the the arcade that can be
opened in that space and you can travel
further in tuning into space
now in journey into space
probably possibly one of the best perks
in the game tough enough is actually
located there so we want to get that
open first and get that into our
possession melee 10 zombies not the best
but this should provide a little extra
so i showed you guys the photos earlier
all these caricatures are actually
people that were devs on the team as
well and there i am zombie that
is head chewed you're beautiful
we have lots of stuff like that that are
just kind of littered throughout the map
that kind of either pay homage to the
team or to various events or you know
movies
uh music videos
all different types of stuff in the 80s
if there's another area you want us to
unlock yeah we're going to unlock
journey into space first so i've got a
little bit of cash in here
uh so this is one of the team door buys
and this is going to allow us to each
deposit a little bit finish the
challenge
i don't like this challenge well i'm
working on cash sorry guys
yeah this is one of those challenges i
actually would recommend us oh that now
oh no you got it it's perfect perfect i
was gonna say either do it on the clown
wave or with insta kill but this is this
is it we got it we got it we got this oh
man that's here done deal cool good job
now you can kill them put a little more
cash in there
some of the designs are like i saw them
right away right like um
you had thriller the thriller jacket i
saw what were some like the other
inspirations for like the clothing
designs and stuff oh well definitely uh
punk rock punk rock was definitely a big
thing that was happening in the 80s so
you're going to notice people with
mohawks and really cool hairstyles like
the flock of seagulls hairstyle
leg warmers that was that was a big
thing uh definitely to see a lot of the
female zombies wearing leg warmers um
and fanny packs multi kids fanny packs
oddly enough fanny packs were like a big
thing i don't know if fanny packs are
going to make the 80s come back or not i
don't know if they're cool enough but
multi kills get get them in a group
and then grenades grenade grenades
there's another set of glasses near me
if anybody wants to pick them up yeah
i'll take them
whoa
yes i was grenading
trying to get them together
oh [ __ ]
only two more
get together zombies right there one
more
we've got 50 seconds we got this it's in
the bag i got no more nades
i got one and
i think that that does it for us nice
and i went down i'm sorry guys okay
oh so we got the challenge i'll be the
sacrificial lamb for it and i got the
cash i'm gonna go ahead and get the door
no no you're leaving oh no wait wait
wait wait he's leaving us
you gotta you gotta help us out here
mary i'm coming i don't know where you
are
i'll stay i'll stay a little further
away so you can run
oh god
oh mama actually will you guys actually
will you guys let me bleed out yeah i
want to oh yeah you want to take the
offer
yeah so we can do that now
totally intentional
all right so i did want to give folks a
chance to take a look at the afterlife
arcade for folks that haven't seen it
um
this is that that location that we've
talked about a bunch where if you die
you can come in here play parlor games
or arcade games
and you can earn your way back to the
living room um my favorite game to play
is either basketball
or cryptic attack they tend to be the
games that can get you scored back into
the game the fastest
nice i'm going to leave one crawler so
you can enjoy yourself
oh all right so this guy we'll just
leave him alive
i'm knocking are you having a good time
if we're lucky there's going to be a
part in here i can collect otherwise
it's somewhere else
dang i want to die
who knew that death could be so fun
so one of the things about the afterlife
arcade is that uh we'll send you here
when you die no matter what uh but we
only actually give you three
opportunities to bring yourself back to
the living so we don't want to we don't
want to abuse the afterlife arcade and
allow players to just come back
infinitely so you only get three
opportunities to come back however you
can always be revived if your teammates
are able to um
if they're able to complete the round so
i'm not going to pick up my lost and
found because that would be a waste
but i am going to pack my weapon
which i just did with my card all right
and safest place is probably right back
here on the bridge near polar peaks guys
yeah where do you want to go next we're
going to open up that journey to space
route all right behind you i think i
have the money
i think we just need a thousand all
right in the polar bear
no not this one uh
the one
let's hang out back here the killer
clowns uh the clown's actually um i
don't know if you guys remember but
there was a television series uh stephen
king's it that came out in the 1980s i
think people remember it it totally
changed the way that people looked at
clowns forever and that was really the
inspiration for getting these killer
clowns in uh
for some reason some people are just
terrified of clowns and it's not even
necessarily in regards to stephen king's
it's not that much of a mystery but uh
yeah also you just made them upsetting
so you can avoid you know you always
want to listen for their squeaky shoes
and their laughter
and here's here's a really fun easter
egg uh we actually have an actress her
name is deborah wilson uh she is
featured in the campaign of the game she
actually is the voice of the clowns
god and she was previously featured on
the show called mad tv way back in the
day
oh shoot i would probably recognize her
face then yeah quite a funny lady but
she's actually she is our clown our
clown voice um all right all right so i
have the i have the first door open we
should follow you i got the money let's
get this next door open right here what
other gun would you recommend in this
area then yeah uh so in this area we've
got the e-rad which is it's going to
spit out a ton of bullets for you which
is going to get you a lot of cash
and that can be found on the wall right
where i'm standing hopping around yep
all
right
it's done oh my god the purchase has
been made all right and i'm gonna go
back and trigger neil so we can keep his
uh his challenges rolling with us
and don't worry too much um if if the
challenges are being failed because we
can always get them going again
and they don't cost anything oh yeah
challenges are free to participate in
and if we complete them then we do we do
earn park tickets which can get us some
really nice goodies as well all right so
where are we unlocking next so we're
gonna unlock this area here which is
going to take us further into germany
this will give us access to the power
switch in this area
and of course we want to get this portal
activated so if you guys hang around
this portal i'm going to turn on the
power
that's easy and we're going to need one
person to
travel through that portal this is the
very first step in opening up the
pack-a-punch room
which is
absolutely crucial in zombies and space
line you really want to have access to
the pack-a-punch room
especially if you don't have the ability
to just play a fate and fortune card and
upgrade your weapon
so we have power restored now i'm gonna
go ahead and flip the switch
and take a ride on the wild side through
the portal
you are
wild all right so
the way you've known you've gone through
is notice that light has turned from
yellow to blue so we have three more
lights that we need to light up let's go
through them
um and you guys can travel through it
and you'll meet me right back on the
other side here
the portal oh if it turned off you'll
have to walk back over sorry mary it's
okay it's good exercise don't worry
remember next next up we're gonna open
up the door that gets us into the arcade
and the arcadis area that features that
laser disco trap that causes zombies to
break dance
i want to see that it's so good so if
you guys want to head back towards me if
i can get one of you to spend your hard
earned cash and open up this door really
i'm actually pretty flush so
get out all right
i'm gonna pick up a black hole grenade
because those are always fun
remember you have your park tickets you
can only spend them at the ticket booths
so let's get the power restored here
and we'll get this portal traverse
through
oh
they are running uh-huh
now it's not only
weapons and equipment that you can buy
there's also items like these gold teeth
oh [ __ ] i'm down sorry
and those are directly tied to an easter
egg we're gonna go on to the dance so
i'm gonna get the dance floor rolling
for us which i believe ashley you are so
calm
in these situations
i just saw you like run through a bunch
of zombies all right so i'm gonna get
off the dance floor so yeah i should be
able to come to you guys so where where
i'm standing this is the safest corner
to be no one will get you here i'm so
i'm coming over to you to get you
hello
how's it going
oh i'm here
beautiful and one other thing that you
could do is before the zombies get
killed because they're in that static
pose just kind of dancing around their
free kills they'll give you more money
so by all means if you want the trap to
give you the tickets you can do that or
you can net a little bit more cash and
you're getting
you're just getting the cash not like us
because you engaged it is that right so
you i'll get the tickets for turning it
on okay um but if you kill them while
they're on the dance floor
gotcha
i'm gonna leave do you wanna all right
so what's the next plan after the dance
all right so what we're gonna do now is
we're gonna actually head up into polar
peaks but before we do that i want to
bring the two of you back this way with
me i'm going to have you buy tough
enough
which is a perk that's going to double
your health and you're going to really
have a much better time running around
this park with it sounds lovely i like
that
so follow me down this way
and of course if you ever run out of
fate and fortune cards you can always
return to the fortune teller to refill
your cards
so here's tough if you have 2500 you can
go ahead and spend that in game cash now
which it looks like you both do
so something that's really cool about
the perks that we did um is we we
created songs for each of them so all
the perks actually have their own song
in game and all of them all the songs
were actually created by guys in the
studio um so one of the
guys on the scene i'm a little concerned
i'm just going to juke him
i can't help you yet yeah don't worry
about me don't worry about me no i can
get you
there's a brute
thanks wow i'm amazed
all right let's head over and get to a
trap so we can get a nice
lot of these guys out of here so we
actually have a trap here that we can
use escape velocity i like it or we can
bring them back to the dance floor and i
highly recommend we bring them back to
the dance i want to see that it sounds
pretty good well not only does it kill
them but it also incapacitates them
exactly he also gets to show off pretty
cool dance moves well there's also um
there's that fan thing that like sucks
all the zombies in oh yeah the
chromosphere yeah that's pretty rad i'm
actually looking at the advertisement
for it right now
so we've got one more door that i need
you guys to get open it's 1500 which is
directly behind me
okay and then we're gonna have one more
door i mean up these stairs yeah we have
one more door now we have trail blazers
here we'll come back for this okay oh
crap
and trailblazers is that perk that lets
us slide and light the ground on fire oh
now if you guys noticed we actually paid
homage to a very famous eighties oh okay
back to the future
you got it back to the future
because those tires those tire tracks
were super famous i think this might be
our down
oh man this might be our down
that bridge was that the same guy that
was that was the brew so the brute will
actually move around the map he will
teleport to be where the players are so
if you outrun him you'll see lightning
up here and he will move to a location
right next to you he's always hunting
you and actually he never goes away
until you kill him he follows you from
scene to scene to scene so once we're
back here let's go ahead and button
through and we'll hop right back in
and we'll keep the same we'll keep the
same strategy running through
what would have been this like he really
cornered us off like what would have
been the solution there that we should
have like prepared for like gosh in a
walkway is never good i feel like every
time we end up cornering ourselves
you're just asking for
a gg scenario
you might as well like find an exit
always have an exit so
we purposefully do that we actually we
have these locations where we want to
funnel the players through these really
tight locations and get the zombies
really close to you now when you're in
the center of spaceland you feel like
you're open and free and you can kind of
run anywhere but those transition areas
getting you into that next space we make
it really tight purposely so that we
really make it claustrophobic and you
don't want to be in that space you don't
want to hang out there okay so i'm going
to turn on the power faster
and we'll get out of here a little bit
quicker this time where the sun doesn't
shine
conserve your money
yeah no weapons in this area
so generally or do you just follow the
same exact route like every time you
play uh i will follow one of two routes
so the the first ride i showed you guys
the other one is i will go up through uh
polar peaks first okay
polar peaks actually has the quickies
perk and i find quickies to be really
really valuable because quickies can
allow you not only to reload your weapon
uh switch weapons faster and things but
it also allows you to board windows
faster
so you can just stop by a window and
pick up 60 cash in about three seconds
which is really really useful
i need some cash there get the door open
all right so we've got the first area
open already i'm going to go ahead and
right away get neal's head all right i'm
going to re-board these and if we're
lucky
we'll get the uh
we'll get the melee challenge first
see we also have an oh here's one of our
easter egg items so i've got our
umbrella atmospheric water vapor now our
umbrella is actually used for one of the
main uh quests uh to fight the uh the
final boss of this this map
um this also
this actually also pays homage to
another 1980s film e.t
uh there was a scene in et where they
had to take a an umbrella and a
speaking spell and a couple of other
devices and they made the device that
allowed e.t to phone home
so we use the seticom once we build it
so that we can phone home to that nice
ufo sitting up on the mountain there
when awakens who awakens this really
nasty little alien that doesn't like us
being in the park and when we're talking
about extraterrestrials i gotta mention
the hop himself that you bring down from
space yes how how did you get him i
assume we used to joke that
you didn't ask for him at the hoff
just knew that he needed to be in this
game and approached you guys
where did that come about
so
we wanted a sl we wanted a celebrity for
sure and we wanted someone that really
uh
i mean hof is the 80s i mean when you
look back
uh at the 1980s i mean he was doing
cameos on shows like different strokes
and things like that so
um
he
he has this really powerful persona and
we knew that the character had to come
off that way in the story uh so he just
he was a really really solid fit for us
not to mention internationally this
guy's he's everywhere uh in germany
again germany
he's the man
i took a trip out there with him and i
have to say
i was real i was really impressed by how
much love david hasselhoff gets out
there yeah and rightfully so man he
deserves it
not very many people get to be famous in
one one decade and then be famous in the
next decade in a show just as big as the
last one so
he's stood the test of time yeah he
really has
all right so we also got a melee six
zombies and pretty quickly when when you
guys have it uh we want to get some cash
into this this journey into space store
okay
let's see we've got some glasses going
on here so the glasses are also an
easter egg homage as well um there's a
movie that was that was in the 1980s
called they live
um
yes
rowdy roddy piper was featured in that
movie and there were these glasses that
when you put them on they let you see
the aliens they let you see what the
real the real world was like i don't
know this movie and so it turned the
whole world black and white and that's
kind of what we did we wanted to turn
the whole world black and white but in
their movie they actually when you
looked at money it said like this is
your god like really weird things like
that so we wanted to we wanted to kind
of pay homage to that we need to uh
melee i think we're gonna miss oh we got
the glasses smacked right have you been
completing the challenges rob no not
really no i know you haven't i've been
actually listening
i can only do one thing
uh-oh
all right looks like we got that
challenge all right where do you want to
go next all right so we're going to go
into the journey to space door which is
right over here and i'm going to go grab
my favorite shotgun in the game
money well spent
good oldie
all right our challenge coming up soon
so i don't know if you guys have noticed
it but there's certain moments in the
game where we actually have the players
communicate and talk to each other um
this is something that we really wanted
to push forward in the story uh kind of
making the players feel more connected
so there are moments where
um especially on on playstation 4 which
is one of my favorite things zombies
is that
when we are not next to each other we
talk through radio communication which
comes through the speaker on your ps4
controller which is actually pretty cool
all right all right
we've only got three more we will
definitely get this challenge all right
there's two
that's it good job
beautiful and pay attention to your the
bottom right hand uh corner of your
screen when your fate and fortune
fortune meter is full you can press the
d-pad up and down to toggle through
and then l1 and r1 will
trigger them if you tap them at the same
time
i'll put a little more cash in there
uh where are you trying to unlock again
let me follow you uh journey into space
right there we go all right i got that
uh
rob
you have money
actually
i just did it
and i'm going to grab insta kill for us
here
a little bit easier do not go into
lasting
i
love crafting
and again we're going to try and get
this door that takes us further to
journey to space
so we can get to the tough perk
no
need party nate party i'm sorry my
eyesight you just get your nades refill
quicker than they normally do yeah and
also if you ever need to see your fate
and fortune cards you can hit the
options button it doesn't pause the game
but it'll give you the details on what
cards you have in your in your slot
available to you
so you make sure you want to you want to
make sure you're in a safe place to do
it but you can always look at those
cards when you need to
and
by all means
feel free to use your grenades they'll
restock after every
all round so we almost got enough to get
this next area open oh i think i could
probably help you out this is this one
right
harden our space dust that's the one
so again we want to get through this
portal and we're going to need to get
through four portals
so i'm going to get the power on and
we'll get that that portal active now we
really want to get to
2500 cash so that we can get the tough
perk
uh because that'll really really help us
out
and from here we're gonna head into the
arcades we can get to that next portal
pretty quickly
all right portal's up
awesome
i'm gonna get that next door open for us
so i had mentioned that there were those
gold teeth that are featured here oh
right um
so we have the the space croc chomp and
it is a it's a sort of a passive trap
that's featured in the map
you can actually knock the teeth out of
that croc and the way that you do it we
might not be able to demonstrate it
today it's kind of challenging to do but
you need to lead the brute underneath
the croc and into his mouth
the brood is so powerful that the crock
mouth can't actually crush him and he
stops it causing the teeth to fall out
oh
now if you bring these gold teeth
if you bring those gold teeth over to
that crock mouth
it might open or expose something to you
that you wouldn't have seen before
inside the croc smell
let us
i love it
let's do it
now of course be careful going inside
the croc's mouth because it doesn't
really get killed by that it loves it
loves just chomping down on you it was a
surprise it seemed pretty hard to
predict uh is it just it has a it has a
a tell so when you first step onto it we
play a sound that lets you know that
it's going to happen and it sort of
rocks back and forth a little bit
and right before it chomps it has it has
one more clicky sound and so if you can
kind of learn that pattern yeah if you
can learn that audio pattern you can
definitely keep yourself safe so we've
got one more door we're going to open up
here that's 1500
okay and you guys are nearing in on 2500
so we might want to grab that tough perk
as a as a backup
it didn't save us last time but i have a
good feeling about it this oh where's
that perk again it is back over in the
german space area
all right
and this infinite grenade i'm going to
pause on picking that up so that we can
actually have zombies around before we
do it that makes sense
i don't think i have enough
and of course our favorite our favorite
wave of all
explosive clowns oh
you know how i love the trailblazers and
i want the
oh man they sound real fun they're the
worst
floating into balls of fire and confetti
oh behind us
oh i totally just down myself i think
nope you're here watch out behind you oh
my gosh i am
oh god
yeah the the traps actually don't affect
the clowns very much
the clowns actually you you real you
just have to take them out
on your own with your gun or melee them
oh is that right which is which is very
dangerous the disco floor doesn't affect
them at all not at all dang so you don't
dance i'm just not into it
yeah i don't think it's their kind of
music
i guess clowns don't really dance
can you really think about it we should
be getting close to the end here
now so is my banshee ammo i need to
we should be getting a max ammo so
everybody reload your reload your weapon
before you
pick we picked this up yup
and now we've got ammo
all right so let's get up through this
space as quickly as we can so that we
don't get trapped here i feel like i
could have gotten that double
the health
i didn't do that yet
all right so now we're going to get the
next
power switch on in just a second here
and this will actually open up the
roller coaster so if you guys want to
hop on the roller coaster
either of you have the glasses
ah i don't why i highly recommend for
players that haven't done it yet
to ride the roller coaster with the
glasses on man there's so much going on
i love it the roller coaster with the
glasses will reveal some really cool
stuff to you
oh god i want to get out of this space
this is a bad place this is a super bad
spot
so what we want to do is get that next
door open okay which one is the one
where rob is
we want to get that door open okay
oh crap
i'm gonna leave a crawler i think just
so we can
do some grabbing items reassess yeah
take a little breather oh god i'm down
nuke perfect timing i'll come you can
get you in just a second oh no well that
refreshes the next one so we need to
open up that door pretty soon then which
door are we opening up oh i did i opened
it all right so it's already this portal
going
unless there's another one yeah he's in
he's he's got it going on
we'll take on again
all right so one of us needs to take the
trip i'll take the trip in the portal
and we want to get that next door open
that's right next to the portal
that's going to lead us out to the try
get it fountain area yes if you can open
that door the one that's right next to
it yeah that's it okay
oh my god i'm making my way back to you
guys now ah
um this is and we want to get we want to
get
so head to the bridge and make a right
okay
and go across that bridge i would yeah i
would get across the bridge because it's
the church
that fountain area that's there yep
there's going to be a slide at the back
of it and just go down the slide it'll
take you back to the center
ah slide
slide slide slides looking for a slide
slide
better
to the right
that guy looks like mugatu
oh i see it mary come to me uh i can't
you're here
okay
you can't i can't
i wish do they slide down they have to
they are gonna follow you down
you got a zombie behind you
i'll take c4 for that
i wanna see them go down
oh they just went on the
stairs not nearly as cool
all right the next door we're going to
open up is the kepler door now that's a
team door by so we're going to work
together uh putting in some tasks that's
in 4 000
if we all put a little we can get to
that pretty quick
work together
let's see i'm gonna go and get tough
just to make sure i don't end up down
again
um
i'm gonna follow you
it's worked for me so far
and how long does that last for
uh so blood clot what that does is
that's going to increase my
time yeah so i'm going to actually end
up with double my time because i think i
have that too
all right so
if you have tough
oh i should get that where is it if you
don't have it yet let's see you're at 9
20. it looks like you need a little bit
more cash
i do yeah
it's uh 2500 he's got him he's at 33.
i'm at 920. okay so you just picked it
up i already got it yet perfect perfect
so we'll come back to the center area
and then we're going to get this uh
kepler door open
kepler system door yeah all right so
that's a thousand i only got 920 so we
got we got some money to make so we've
got one roaming zombie it seems like
i did leave a crawler
awesome so i'm going to take a moment to
put a little cash in my pocket by
boarding some windows
it's like building a fork
i'm not sure where he is could be i'm
gonna pause our challenge
since we all have grenades
and we have a couple of places that i
can search for
easter egg items so i'll look for those
while we're looking around here
so normally on this bench you'd find the
calculator
but it is not there sorry i had to kill
her no that's quite all right she found
me
all right the next round has
let's go ahead and unpause our
robot here
oh man uh you guys reload ammo oh five
multi kills right yeah so it's gonna be
grenades if you got them
grenade kills that we can get
and brute is in the house oh no it was
just announced by willard i see him he's
there
where he's ugly
so i'm gonna need to get a different gun
so i can work on him i'm going to do
that now i don't know if it's in our
best interest to do multi kills while
there's a freaking
dang he's killing all these other
zombies is he kind of what a nice guy
yeah he actually will swipe the zombies
and take their body part and then throw
it at you now should we
avoid how
i'm going to call in armageddon we
should clear out quite a few zombies and
we're going to get out of this corner
because this is a bad place to be going
oh no oh no
i'm gonna make a dash oh my god
yeah so armageddon is quite a
powerful uh
piece of equipment that you can pick up
um it's 50 tickets in the ticket booth
and you can trigger it with l1 and it
will just randomly drop
bombs all over the map
and while not an 80s movie we're we've
we've definitely wanted to uh have some
fun and uh have comets coming down just
like the movie armageddon
all right i'm gonna work on similar
brute here watch out get out of that
laser
all my round of grenades
all right so we want to get his helmet
off once his helmet's off we just want
to get him in the face
hey
where is he going he's going in he's
shooting oh [ __ ] run
oh he's still coming i'm stuck in the
corner
oh he got his all right he's dead
nice and he let uh uh ammo
all right so if you want to reload your
weapons all right i'm gonna touch it
yeah we'll leave him leave him
uh i'm gonna touch it
he's like a little pet
he's he's our little dude hey little
dude no did you plead out again do you
play more oh i didn't i just came to get
a couple of extra tickets because like i
had mentioned if we buy those gold teeth
we can actually trigger an easter egg
and also there's a there's a an uber
powerful weapon in this in this arcade
um it's called the forge freeze and this
can actually freeze the zombies where
you can just walk up to them and smash
them but it's it's 500 tickets so we got
to earn a few more tickets to get that
and then of course we want to get the
300 tickets we can get that a set of
gold teeth i like that
so i want to come back over here because
this is something you guys should really
pay attention which is trailblazers all
right we're going to look for you i see
you i'm going to come to you real fast
so trailblazers what's great about it is
it's not only going to leave that trail
of fire behind you but it's going to
light zombies on fire that are going to
take they're going to take damage uh
slowly but surely now when you're low on
cash or low on ammo trail blazers is a
great way to get you back can we get it
right now if you have the if you have
the cash for it i would absolutely
recommend it's 1500 and it's in here
it's right at the bottom of the steps
when you um exit the polar peaks area
oh behind yeah so we want to and
definitely we want to get out of this
lane here yeah oh crap
oh [ __ ] i'm putting myself in a pretty
bad spot here all right well i'm behind
i'm gonna pick up infinite ammo just let
your gun rip
so if you have an automatic firing
weapon let it go
shoot everything
especially in a world where yeah ammo is
money
such a beautiful perk
such a beautiful thing so beautiful
oh it's done okay
oh
[ __ ] get oh no
i'm fine oh
just needed a hot juke
there
like a little bit of a choke point here
where did you guys go
i'm in that fountain area got it i'm
going to fountain too then here we go
and i'm going to head back down
to the
kepler door i've got about 2700 i can
put 2 000 of that in
i got 16. we're pretty close to getting
to that package
wait will you watch me walk down the
slide
ready watch her
watch me
oh yeah where's the trail
so trailblazers if you follow me through
this doorway here
straight ahead
through both doors you'll see it on your
left right when you get to the steps
that's it
okay i'm going to get the kepler door
open
and now we only need one more door
and we should be able to get that pack
of punch going
now i recommend if the weapon that you
drop the nuke let's hold on to that um
i recommend if you um
if you have the cash and you don't love
your weapon
find the weapon that you really love
because whatever you pack a punch you're
gonna you're probably going to want to
stick with that for a while
so if you're happy with it hang on when
are we going to use that nuke uh it's
going to flash in a second so as soon as
it starts flashing i'm going to pick it
up
are there any weapons you recommend as
far as packing up
well the banshee is great um however
when you run into the brute the banshee
can be trouble
so the nv4 which i'm running right now
you can pick up in the arcade it's at
the back of the arcade
all right it's an assault rifle i'm
flush with cash all right so we're going
to open up this door here
okay
and
the portal that's directly in front of
us there as soon as i turn this power on
is the one we need to go through
one up here
right
oh [ __ ] yeah
um getting crazy where's the portal oh
you got it
i think this is a bad area
yeah it's tight in there we just want to
get through the portal and out of there
i'm
leaving and be careful if you go through
the crock mouth
so remember i talked about bringing
those gold teeth over so if you get
these teeth knocked out
this door
can be opened with those gold teeth
and there is a very very very powerful
attachment for your weapons behind that
door
christ
i want it i want to go through the teeth
but i'm afraid because i can't hear it
oh no
i think it's going to come down i'm down
it's terrifying it's terrifying how do
you know when it's going to come down
you got to look for that wiggle and
listen for the click wiggle and click
yes
all right sorry i'll try and get back up
to you in just a second here
it's okay i kind of want to play a
minigame
i got you oh thanks
except i lost all my parrots of course
sorry i'm sorry
i thought you were zombie i shot you
there is a fate and fortune call card
called perk insured that if you go down
you actually won't lose your perks
and that's one of those fortune cards we
talked about earlier that's super
powerful and definitely you want to use
them damn
all right so we got two more to go
through which i can get to right now
where are you at
i am back at the center portal
do you guys want to take that center
portal by all means please do
we get to go backwards
all right this way right yeah
yeah i need to get health
you mean the double health
that's in that's in journey to space
right that is in journey to space back
and drainage space
we have not acquired the gold teeth yet
not yet
but that i should be able to pick up
pretty quickly um
assuming we can get to a crawler and
then just let him hang out for a minute
while we uh play a couple of arcade
games hit that one already all right
i just need a little pick-me-up of
health
hi how are you
hi how are you
you're back
okay oh we're all together
we've
done fairly well i probably don't have
enough money for a pack-a-punch that's
okay oh it sounds like final round oh
this is my favorite part
when you thought it was safe to go back
in the water you know what i just
realized see those clowns i could
probably use more ammo pretty soon
well if you do pack a punch on that
weapon you should get full hammer right
and then we'll get full-on monkeys all
right so pack a punch is now open if you
return to the center portal however you
need 5 000 cash yeah definitely not
going to make that one oh you guys you
might in time
i heard you're controlling me it did it
made a noise
yeah we send quite a few notifies
through the controller so like when you
rank up you'll get a notify uh when we
have uh the player-to-player moments of
dialogue we'll let that come together
controller speaker we definitely want to
have fun with that um
even though it's not on every platform
it's something that we can do that's
platform specific yeah that's really
really cool what i like have made the
mistake and i keep forgetting to turn it
back on in my house like i had to turn
it off for some game that overdid it
it was just like too loud and too
consistent so i feel like i've been
missing out on so many games to like
utilize it correctly yeah well hopefully
we're not beating you over the head with
it no it doesn't sound like it at all
like just a chime here and there it's
cool yeah so hopefully uh people have it
on and they're they're getting the
experience because it really does make
it feel a little more authentic yeah
especially when we're far apart in the
park and you're kind of getting in that
radio message coming in yeah it's cool
all right so like i said the pack of
punches open
i don't have enough money for it yet oh
you're close
now one thing that we can also do is if
anybody is stacked with cash oh there's
a max ammo if anybody stacked with cash
we can actually deposit money into the
atms
and you can uh withdraw it if you need
it no kidding so if you went down you
could go back to it yeah you can you can
so if you were banking a ton of cash you
want to put it in the atm in the event
that you go down you don't lose any of
it wow and then you can recover that
money go right back to the lost and
found and recover all your items now not
your perks but all your equipment all
your weapons
that's always the worst part
is like once you go down and you're like
you know
on level 10 or 15 it's just like not
even worth it sometimes all right so i'm
gonna actually throw a thousand in there
because i got a little more than i need
let's get throw these guys down and then
i'll head into the package
oh we got a brute here great oh great
let me lead him away from you guys and i
can get rid of him
um it's getting a little it is crazy
you guys are at 14. this is pretty
pretty good very behind your breast oh
god
i threw a grenada
we're at we're at that point uh
definitely getting slapped a lot more
than usual
yeah i'm like burning through you get so
much more cash now though too all right
where's the um i have enough now
for the weapon
so you want to go back to that center
portal
baby
there's no time uh-oh
where do we go
uh leave a crawler i can do that just
don't yeah there's one crawler over here
i'm gonna leave him leaving me
all right it looks like you guys have
the cash for pack-a-punch so why don't
you guys head into the portal
oh my
uh
we going in
aren't you aren't we waiting
no you wanna you wanna pack a punch your
weapon definitely do it oh okay uh which
one is this one
is it
is it this guy
uh that's it here we go so you guys go
ahead and upgrade
i love you for about 10 46 seconds
all right and make sure make sure not to
leave your gun in the pack punch make
sure you pick it back up yeah
i've played with a few people that have
actually left their men behind now we've
started a new round we've started a new
round that is
but we're in good shape if you've got a
pack a punched weapon now
this wave is going to be a lot easier
uh what's top class
dropped a perk
oh my god i gotta get out of there all
right now i'm going to pack a punch
oh it's not ready for me
wow
yeah that makes a difference
okay you probably have a larger clip
your gun is definitely doing more damage
and that'll that'll help in these later
rounds
is there anything that you can allude to
i know you said you don't want to
obviously give anything away to people
who
love
zombies and they want to like figure
this stuff out on their own but is there
anything maybe you could allude to that
people haven't tried or even gotten
close to that you're like
if only they knew
uh yeah i think there's definitely a
couple of things that people haven't um
haven't gotten
they haven't even actually gotten close
to yet is that just based on the wave
number like
uh it's not based on waves it's
discoverability they just actually
haven't put two and two together yet
um so there's still there are still
easter eggs out there that haven't been
discovered um
there's an easter egg
oh there's parts of an easter egg that
are going to happen in this map
that are going to continue on for some
time um
i don't want to give away too much but
we're going to have something
i think that are going to get fans very
excited that stick with us
my melee still upsets me it's a broken
bottle it seems really nice oh hey guys
uh we do have insta kill so it should be
smooth sailing
if you eat me
i don't know how much longer we have it
i really want to go under the teeth
i see it i see it dipping
with your left
so i have the chromosphere trap on if
you want to come over by it it will
definitely
keep you safe if you need a moment to
chill out
i'm scared of going under those teeth
yeah me too one sprint we'll get you
through
oh god oh god
i'm down sorry how about that oh bye
no i was waiting you know i was waiting
for the teeth and then yeah and the
zombies got me from behind i'm gonna try
to crawl through this croc mouth anxiety
it gets a lot of people all right i have
anxiety
stop stop move don't get under the tooth
okay don't stop
could you rest me dude
the teeth
like god that's the tips of your shoes
you're so close to dying i got you up i
know oh so we're not going
oh what's this
so sort of another easter egg yeah you
can earn tickets by playing this uh
watch our back that guy i just shot was
me
so all of the the civilians that show up
are also devs that that are in this game
as well
all right so you can earn a couple of
tickets there and now i'm actually going
to pack a punch so i can
hang with you guys since you guys are
all
hulked out now
i mean
mary needs help
i think l1 puts those on
so if people haven't paid close
attention
they should pay close attention
to what i'm looking at right now
this is tied to a very big easter egg
pay close attention to these symbols on
the ground his screen's more interesting
than our screen and notice we don't let
you stay in here forever
but pay close attention to this room
and pay close attention to everything
that's in there not the exact
temperatures that's what i was expecting
but better than nothing
there's a huge wave coming after you
go down there i couldn't get it i'm down
guys don't worry about me you guys
finished the wave this is it
i was watching his screen
it's more interesting
i'm sorry i'm going to play some arcade
games come on boys
do you guys ski ball
what the heck am i supposed to do
all right
what's the cooldown on pack a punch
um
there is so you can't so you couldn't go
in and pack one weapon and immediately
go back in okay so it's like a round
yeah we want to basically we don't want
to put players into that location for
too long because it definitely it
it gets all the spawners onto the other
players which makes it really brutal
sure
but we also don't want to give them a
safe haven to go run to
we want to keep you moving keep it
intense
unless you're dead
then we slow it down just a little bit
for you
get in there
i could probably use a different leather
i'm going to get about 95 more tickets
in a moment and i'm going to work on
getting an arcane attachment
and we're going to go trigger an easter
egg with that uh oh
i'm having a great time
i'm not
damn it i got stuck
i'm not
so one thing that's always helpful yes
is you can always bring up your
inventory screen and you can see the
items that you've collected you know
exactly what they go to and you can kind
of track your progress as you're going
through zombies in space land
so there's there are oh i think i got
myself stuck in a corner
no
sorry
so there are there are the four weapons
that you can get which are the zombies
spaceland zappers
um which are featured around the park
there are three parts that you need to
find for them
but assembling them gives you
uh one of them will will make zombies
break dance
one of them will fire shots that
ricochet all over the place um and
there's one that actually will cause
zombies to blast off like a rocket and
explode like fireworks i've seen that
yeah there's some there's some really
interesting things that you can find
there so
that pack-a-punch is really the first
step that's the first easter egg that
you really want to go for when playing
zombies in spaceland it's the thing that
sort of uh it evens the tide for for all
the players um
there's a point i think right around
scene 9 or 10 where your base weapons
just won't cut it anymore you'll run out
of ammo really fast
and you'll definitely exhaust your
grenades before you know it
so the pack-a-punch open the portals
right away get to those portals as
quickly as you can and there's
definitely a
a path that's least expensive so the
path that we took into journey into
space is the least expensive path to get
all the portals open and to get the the
whole map basically flowing
all right
i love it well we probably have time to
do one more round yeah um let's try it
and yeah before before we try to attack
something before we jump in can i i want
to update my fate and fortune cards i'm
going to throw something nice in there
probably can't but so let's throw in
this will help all of us power up drops
and
that's always fun
and some of these fortune cards can give
you weaponry too
as an example you can get the claw
weapon with unlimited ammo for 30
seconds which is one of the mp supers
that you can get
and it it is really really fun to use
against the zombies
we'll throw get packed on there and
bullets we're gonna go big today
and we'll make our melee deadly
and i think i'm ready if you guys are
let's do it
um do you guys ever take like requests
from people who want to see specific
things in in zombie mode
um like there's certain things that
they've always asked for different
power-ups different cards
oh yeah absolutely um we're pretty
active on reddit we're pretty active on
twitter
um we're always listening to the
community there's fantastic ideas out
there um
we
will
sometimes look at things and go wow
exactly how it's described sounds
awesome but as an example
the perk that we have trailblazers is
actually homage to a perk that was made
in the mod community called banana
colada it became really popular among
the mono community
where you would slide and it would cause
all the zombies to slip until they die
so we we kicked it up a notch and we
obviously added our our tire marks and
set the ground on fire
uh we light them on fire instead of them
slip around yeah i like that um but we
wanted to provide a power to players um
when they slid around the map
and who knows there might be more perks
coming along in the future
new ones that players have never seen
before
i actually i really like how there's
just one map and you guys just like
polish it and jam pack it with so much
stuff right it's not like it's a massive
map you guys have just put so much stuff
in it there's like 80 different ways to
approach it
yeah it's actually uh it's a
pretty diverse space as you guys have
probably begin to find out the spaces
play very differently
uh there's a location we actually didn't
go into yet which is the underground and
it is very very claustrophobic down
there no um but unfortunately because
it's claustrophobic down there we stuck
a bunch of easter egg parts
so of course you're gonna have to go
down there now one of one of the really
really uh cool easter eggs that we have
that provides some really really awesome
perks to the player
starts off right here
pop these balloons
and when i pop them all
hear that sound yeah you want to look
for that sound around the map when you
hear that that means you are on to
something oh my gosh
so we're giving you a little bit of a
clue and i'm actually going to take you
guys when we get back into the arcade
i'm going to take you and
show you something that's in the arcade
that i don't know if everybody has seen
it i think a couple of people out there
might have found it
i'm going to show you something that
people should pay attention to
i just found a robot
i guess i got an umbrella
again
sorry
through the first door i'm gonna get
neal's head back on
now obviously if we were if we were cool
enough and good enough uh we could have
completed all of neil's challenges which
would have led us to having to collect
his next part
uh his next part is a battery that we
need to find
by returning the battery to neil uh
he'll kick off the second round of
challenges and then if we find his last
part which is a floppy disk
he'll kick off the last round and if we
complete all of them we have the ability
to walk up to neil and call in in our
case since we're only playing with three
we could call in a fourth player uh
which would be david hasselhoff who
comes down to fights alongside you yeah
it's really fun watching him
come down from space i haven't seen him
and he's a decent shot too like he's
actually a really helpful player he's a
pretty good shot why don't we get the
hoff this round
we haven't done it yet it's funny it
makes me laugh
let's try it all right let me get the
robot did you already get it i have the
robot so we have just don't go into last
stand as the first challenge
well we'll try and focus focus on
challenges yeah let's do it
see that face
i think my i think my favorite zombies
are cops yeah we got insta kill here
i'll wait for a moment see if
it lasts through this round of
challenges
wait for it to flash
oh [ __ ] oh it's all right it's all right
don't worry about it i didn't see it god
damn it wrong
well hopefully the challenge they throw
at us right now is is melee because if
we get it with melee that makes life
really easy
let's see what we get
oh
and we got melee kill 10 zombies
wouldn't you know it
hold on to that kill huh
yeah i don't know if it would have
lasted that long
it don't feel too bad god picked that up
figures out
all right just shoot them in the leg
and then slap him to death punch to the
face
just really easy to like accidentally go
down on this round by just being take
slapping off more than you can
chew
all right there's one
all right sorry i went down because
no worries
thank you
i really could use
a banshee
god i love that gun
oh clown round it's going to get
exciting
where is that banshee right in this the
starting area so when you're first
coming over the bridge out of that uh
right by the park yep thank you
that's exactly the reaction we want for
people to kind of gasp like oh man what
is happening
they're right there
oh kill ten zombies from a distance so
this this one's actually with the clowns
this makes it pretty easy right because
they explode each other exactly oh we
just have to keep them with the white
outlines yeah they have the white
outline right
i'll get these guys on the bridge
this should work behind you five more
five more five more we got it we got a
minute we should we should get this
damn it they got two
got it cool
we're getting there
oh
they're still coming huh that's right
yeah the challenge is done but the round
isn't done but the clowns are not
clowns aren't done with this yet clowns
are never done i love these clowns
you can hear some music in the
background
all right to reload those guns it's 80s
delicious all right
go for it okay
all right
the next challenge should be coming
along
let's kneel configures for us
get five multi kills right use your
nades
yeah this one can be tricky because you
gotta get them together
i'm just trying to get them
near each other here
so
oh here we go um more
oh come on do it yeah
all right good job
and now kill the zombies
tell them
oh i got a nuke okay i would hold it i
think we can take care of this pretty
easily
or maybe i don't know because it blinks
right how long does those last it can't
be more than like 20 seconds it's about
15 seconds it'll start blinking right
before it's gonna take off
and it'll flash three times before it
goes away
i'm observing it
i think we're probably down to one or
two oh it's blinking okay sorry i know
it's all good because that'll clear us
throughout the map for us
okay jumping
all right i have the first journey to
space store open so we only have a
minute 20 to get these jump kills yes so
let's do it
so how do i get you to talk to me come
look at me i'm behind you
i just want to see like does my nerd guy
say anything particularly
uh he he definitely has his own
one-liners you have the glasses yet if
you don't have we yeah
all right jump jump jump
yeah depending on who completes a
certain action when you're playing
together uh the dialogue will actually
change depending on who triggers your
events first
all right
we're almost there
how much time
good job
i feel like
we should be getting pretty close
to ha
well i think we completed all the first
round of neil's challenges now we got to
get that batteries we're going to work
on uh i got a max ammo over here do you
guys want to reload yeah i'm good ready
when you are okay here we go
and we now have the tough enough perk
turned on
in case you need that oh i do
yes please
yeah that was dope okay we got the first
portal done
i can't help it this is who i am who are
you you're the job
hey
did you guys get uh tough enough i did
um i still got uh i'm still pretty
flushed too so if you wanna can we get
this can we get this door open i don't
recommend you coming down here with me
yet
because this area is going to be really
squeezy
squeezy
i'm doing it
leave me up here yep
all right
i want to see this area
can stay up here but i
what were you looking for i'm looking
for the microwave which sometimes
appears so it changes
location yeah like the mystery box
almost yep
yeah we don't put the items in the same
place twice so every game you play we
ship them around
so you're having to look around a little
bit to find stuff
man this is a really cool area
like every room is like a potential
easter egg yeah well the really good
thing about this space is that if you've
picked up the banshee there's another
banshee down here so you can actually
hang out around here for a while
and restock your ammo yeah
so though it is claustrophobic if you
take the right weapon down here
you can be pretty effective
how's it going down there guys
this is one of the zappers i was talking
about
the shredder
oh sure causes the zombies to just
dismember and fall so some assembly
required is that like the um like the
portal pieces in the tickets
yeah so basically in order to get that
weapon you're gonna have to collect
those three parts okay
um and then you go down there and get it
yeah two of which we can find in the
world and then one of which we actually
have to uh we're gonna have to do an
event
uh with these little ufos
oh okay and that's in the pack of punch
room right yeah we have to lead them out
of the pack-a-punch room so we're gonna
have to bring one of us is going to have
to purchase the arcane attachment and
bring it into the uh
the portal
and once you're in the pack-a-punch room
that'll free out those those ufos
uh we are on to scene nine
are you guys still down there i am still
still down here okay go back up
i'm okay
but like now that i'm down here
i'm just too afraid to go anywhere else
well
he can't protect you forever
but oh money but yes you can
and i don't know
yes he can
try all right let's see
we got double cash
pretty nice that like makes you want to
hoard your cash
oh god
it's time to pit my ride no i'm taking a
lot of fire here all right
oh that was definitely a claustrophobic
area
yeah
that's unfortunate
i should be able to
i'm flush with cash because i killed
somebody i have the magic wheel near me
if anybody's looking for something cool
in the wheel okay
crap
mistakes
i'm gonna try it out
give me something good
reward me
the emc is that worth it
it's not great
it's not like getting an axe or a ford
freeze but it's certainly good who's
that first bad guy he comes at 10 right
wave 10. that the brute yeah the brute
uh he can show up around wave 10. no
never exactly the the same wave a jerk
oh dmr that can't be useful at all can i
find you guys
if you're good with a sniper that's a
pretty sweet gun to have there's also a
card that does crits for any sniper kill
can i open up this door to come see you
guys or
where are you at
i am
yeah you can uh just be careful going
through this room
these bumper cars are active and if they
hit you and you are down
so the lights will flash white or red
before they move so you always get a
tell before they're actually going to
take yes that has harmed me
before this is much like the croc mouth
it's this is one of those areas that
people are very apprehensive to come
through but it's really great if you
time it right and bring a train of
zombies through there you can actually
take quite a few of them out for free
let's see if the magic box hangs around
for a while
i'm gonna get inside that arcade spin on
the wheel
i've spun it too many times
now i'm rocking a sniper rifle he's a
gambler
i like to gamble
that's why i live in an alley
um
did we get the hoth yet we haven't we're
we have to get two more quest parts
um and we're gonna have to complete uh
two more sets of challenges so we're
working on getting that next quest part
now oh
insta kill oh we got a brute so beware
can we insta kill whoa the knight items
that kill the root that seems
oh lord
root's not down with insta-kill
oh god laser
come on
oh i'm out of ammo with my banshee
already yeah all right it's time to slap
people
this weapon
oh it's the brute he's not cutting it
oh he's coming for me
oh
oh lord yeah behind me behind you behind
you found us i'm down
did he find me
i don't i don't know rob
i was right next to you i was
i think he kept moving i can get you i
can get you okay
are you in the alley okay
he's on me so he's over there i'll
distract him i would run
okay come into the arcade we can trigger
the disco trap to chill everybody else
out
and then we just got to focus on brutus
maximus over there
all right i'm going to come to you
this guy sucks
oh he's throwing stuff that's right yeah
he'll throw zombie parts
oh god i forgot about the bumper cars
can we bumper car the brute you cannot
root is too tough for a bumper car
oh let's get him on the dance floor
he doesn't dance he's just a big jerk no
i thought he does dance root does not
dance oh
really that's that's an interesting idea
though
would you guys like to see the brood
dance yeah i would i would like to see
him do a nice disco
disco i like that
i know that's more 70s but i still for
the worm he should do the work
i just went down from the bird's heart
oh no
i got the baby doing the warming
oh no all right let's calm that room
down for a second
i really need ammo
no this guy
look at this so this is the first guy at
the wedding right here
the first guy at the wedding oh he's got
the right idea wow these moves are so
hot
come on brute
get on the dance floor i die don't i or
i will eventually
are you down well no the this is this
will hurt me right with the disco lights
come on pretty sure yeah you can't stand
in the lasers that'll damage you
oh it's the brood
you missed the dance buddy
so i have the arcane core we need but i
have to get some animal first
that machine i was i was telling you
guys about you notice we have all these
atari 2600 arcade games here
but this one there's one that's not like
the other
oh are you giving us a little uh oh
people want to learn about secrets oh
they should pay attention to that ghost
and skulls arcade machine right now you
should do it now when there's a brute
running around there's so many clowns oh
we have a lot to do in order for us to
get through that clowns fruit clowns
down
clowns and brood
sounds like a great match might be it
for you guys yeah let's just run out of
here lee bye mary
i'm gonna crawl
oh honey oh my god oh my god
you can actually melee the clowns
um just try just trying not to do like
two or three at the same time
yo i ain't going out like that oh the
brew and the clowns fruit and clowns as
well like no money sorry guys i have so
much money i feel like we haven't shared
our wealth equally here
that that the economy can be a problem
you definitely need to share and share
alike
i should have me guys but nope all right
i'm playing an arcade game rob you're
the only one you can do it am i really
yeah you're the last okay i'll go down
this basement
what it's pretty
yeah it's a surprise they won't
understand
oh oh
i wish i would have known
today at the ghost and schools arcade
machine there's actually one in here
and that machine updates
uh it actually says zero of six but for
us it says one of six
so for your audience the very first step
to that easter egg is popping the
balloons in the starting area oh i so
screwed up so bad and if they return to
the glass and skulls arcade machine
they'll see that
they'll be one of six
you're in my arcade
hey
and this is a little homage to a game
that we made a while back which was
extinction and call of duty ghosts this
is one of our cryptid aliens
in cartoon form
this isn't i mean this is going okay oh
rob says he's doing all right i'm sorry
i'm just running from a giant brute
trying to kill pods at the same time
no pressure no pressure
okay
um you want me to go to the atm yeah to
distribute you can uh i'm going to
reload you guys can this is to withdraw
i want to deposit here uh opposite side
oh crap
hey lee how do i perfect max ammo how do
i get out of here
uh if you turn let me see i gotta
all right
i just deposited a lot of money uh you
want to go straight towards the brew
okay so then and then hang a left um i
just got here yeah go into the arcade
and then take the portal and bring it to
the center there's a money symbol out
here we could double our cash
do that for sure um boy i lost my rpm
unfortunately
let's see
hey yeah
watch out
oh oh i'm down he came out oh my gosh
i came out i got stuck oh no
god no pressure no pressure mary there's
a brute no pressure there's a proof
i'm dead
shoot
we certainly tried we certainly tried
the brute is right yeah we want to
recover that battery uh it can appear in
the arcade that's one of the locations
that we could grab it from unfortunately
was not there for us today that's all
right that was a good that was a good
round and i think that's a pretty good
uh overview of the new call of duty's
zombies mode um 80's tastic anything
else any other tidbits anything else
that you want to say uh i just want to
touch back on the stuff i talked about
earlier which is use those fate and
fortune cards don't shy away from using
the fortune cards uh the weapon kits are
really useful as you guys saw my banshee
was much better than yours that's true
it was a much better banshee so hook
yourself up make sure you're taking
advantage of all that stuff and just if
you log in every day you're going to get
the free bonus every day so it just kind
of inches you forward you don't even
have to be very good you're just going
to get that bonus every day sweet thanks
a lot for your time thank you for having
me thanks for joining us and thank you
guys for watching
uh so you guys please stick around we're
gonna have a lot more coverage on
gamespot.com thanks a lot bye